it's not how quick can you do it it's
when you do it so
she's not actually looking at the wrist
she's looking into his eyes
she never once looks at his wrist when
she's doing the watch deal
hi my name's lee thompson i'm a
pickpocket for hire
for well over 32 years now i get hired
by banks insurance companies as well as
theatrical pickpocketing for west end
shows
today we're looking at pickpocketing in
movies and gonna judge just how real
they are
[Music]
on the chicago loop i would actually see
lots of businessmen
reading newspapers and this steal is
spot on
the interaction the amount of eye
contact it's not too much he doesn't
knock him over it's a little whoops the
guy
is shielding his own pocket with his
newspaper that he's reading
he's already done the pickpocketing work
for the pickpocket
unknowingly the technique is beautiful
and
we're watching it from a spectators
point of view
he's not trying to move away because
he's there's no heat on him
but he will get out of that carriage
when i work with the police we often
tell people about a thing called looping
where you might think i know that person
you don't but you've
subconsciously you've seen them a couple
of times in a short space of time
because they're not getting anywhere but
they've got an agenda the london
underground
is notorious for pickpockets because
it's crowded
it's been reported that there's in one
station alone it was 139 cases of
pickpocketing
close your bag keep it in front of you
especially on a
crowded tube or metro it's a 10.
the technique is beautiful and
unfortunately
it does happen
as he raises his arm he's actually
raising his pocket
to her hand so she has to stand like
that and
clip whatever she needs to clip and then
when he puts his arm down
the pocket moves away from the item and
his peripheral vision her head is to his
right side
he can't see anything over this right
side
now i'm not telling you this so you go
out and do it i'm telling you this so
you don't
be a victim of it the greater movement
supersedes that of the lesser movement
or the greater force
supersedes that of a leftist force so
they say if i tap your leg
with a pencil and then hit your shoulder
with a hammer you'll forget me tapping
the pencil
leg but you'll feel the hammer so
misdirection and slight hand is super
important
and you can easily do that we've got a
piece of paper or an envelope
it's not a bulky item so it's not
perfect
i would give it an eight
[Applause]
oh i love it i love it
i think this movie is super
well choreographed
the pressure in gripping that
purse or that wallet with the chopsticks
you're gonna have to be pretty
spectacular gripping
uh most people can't even pick up sushi
so a heavy purse with coins in maybe we
don't know what's in there
would be trickier but it can be done
i've done things like this on behalf of
the police
to draw attention as a crime prevention
but just to show people how easy it was
and how vulnerable they are
yeah 100 she could um
because he's moving and she's moving
he's not
static so the movement is covering
all her movement definitely she's taking
that leather strap watch with that
technique because if you look
the crystal is really heavy so when you
undo
the tongue bit through the prongs the
weight of the crystal will make the wall
the watch fall away from the wrist so
and what's actually happening is he's
actually moving away from the watch
the friction could make him look what's
going on so
he's actually aiding it himself
unknowingly and the weight of that
crystal would make it
fall away easier for her it's not how
quick can you do it it's when you do it
so
she's not actually looking at the wrist
she's looking into his eyes
and she's constantly looking into his
eyes she never once
looked at his wrist when she's doing the
watch steal you might think there's a
lot going on that would never happen
but you're looking from a bird's eye
view but they're all communicating
with telephones earpieces and with
visual signals people at street parties
who have been drinking are easy targets
because one the inhibitions have gone
and that
makes the element of surprise better for
the pickpocket to get close to you
my colleague apollo robbins i can see in
the clips because i can tell his body
language and i know what he looks like
was involved in this it's phenomenal i'd
give it 10 out of 10.
my eyes would be gravitated towards it
straight away as a very vulnerable
item to steal i think most people have a
wallet or foolishly their phone in the
back pocket
[Music]
so that misdirection is beautiful we do
it for crime prevention we put pocket
in reverse to say i can put it in your
pocket
i can easily take it out your pocket
unfortunately
you might think well he's just taking a
phone off a bar
that no one's watching that's not what
this distraction technique is about
you wouldn't have a hundred percent
certainty
how it's going to go because it's
evolving instantly
in real time because someone the guy
might have turned around and copped him
he's constantly self-directing and
self-evaluating the
instant there is no i'm going to do this
this or this he's got lots of avenues to
change his tactics
you look and go where's the busiest
place i can be
that you're going to go to a busy place
because you can hide
if any books or pictures you see a
pickpocket always seem to do that pincer
movement
and that is because you can grab the
side of the wallet without
making contact with his backside that
pocket is quite a wide pocket most
people who've got denim jeans have tight
pockets these days
it's a bit hard to steal from but
they're a standard pair of jeans with a
baggy back pocket
that is an easy easy dip some wallets
are pleather some are leather
i would be tempted to put it in your
front pocket and turn it sideways
so it would jam he doesn't know what's
in the wallet he doesn't know if there's
credit cards in there cash in there
whereas the phone the smartphone
nowadays we have so much of our personal
information
stored on that phone look after your
phone that would have been the thing
i would have stolen i carry a wallet
it's a decoy wallet
you're going to get nothing don't keep
all your id
in one place because he's got everything
he would casually walk out the bar if
someone runs your eyes
dart to the person running and in
reality if this is real life the stuff
i've done for the police
those ids and credit cards have gone
to someone who knows someone who knows
someone who
knows someone who can crack all the
information there
if it was broken down into individual
things i would give it a 10 out of 10.
this has happened all together for a
small payoff
he's covering his back a little bit too
much for my liking i would have liked to
been out there
by now but i'd say 9.
how are you doing here the chances of
her having anything in that pocket
it's highly unlikely because it's quite
it's quite a smart
trouser suit and the pocket's high and
although for
the girl in the clip being small down is
really advantageous to be in a
pickpocket
because you're low down to people's bags
and pockets
but the black canary is quite a tall
lady compared to her
so she's got to reach up into the pocket
and
it's just the timing is wrong 100 she
would catch her
it could be that the the three finger
dip if you like
it doesn't matter they don't three
fingers a whole hand she's a child
who's got small hands
i hate that bit i hate it clearly
just done for the movie zero technique
to do a bracelet how do you know what
clasp is on the bracelet
there are so many different sorts does
it come over the hands
if it's over the hand there's one
important thing that gets in the way
that's the thumb
she just takes it off but her hand is on
the bench
so she's got to go under to find the
clasp and it clearly
undoes from underneath fake
it's a normal thing that you would be
used to seeing someone's broken their
arm or they've got it in a sling or
people carry babies in front of them
that are not babies as a a doll
you can buy realistic babies i've
actually witnessed and seen the babies
and i do the baby trick
myself everything is doable so
i would give this out of ten
an eight pay very very close attention
because i'm about to bend this spoon
with my mind
what's this what are you doing looks
like we got a spoon in a stem
i find this bit really disappointing
because the whole of the movie
is all about the magician's skill and
technique that they practice for hours
and hours a skill and technique that you
don't see but whereas this clip is not
clear at all
you see him take a spoon it's not clear
what's going on and then
the reveal at the end is like i don't
think
that actually really happens
wallet chances are a pickpocket would
take advantage of that crowd build
and unbeknown to you try and pickpocket
that crowd i don't believe
realistically that the street performer
would want to steal from you
obviously there's a lot of it's cgi's
for the camera
but there are magicians that do
manipulation acts that can do that with
cards there are people called card
ninjas who throw cards for mile
not miles but yards and yards in a
certain direction
but the problem is with magicians they
practice slight hands that you don't see
so it's very rare that you would
actually see something exactly like now
you see me
it's hard to judge on the skill level
because the narrative
is not clear
but i checked my pockets if i was you
because i do believe she lifted your
timepiece
she's bumped in and covered all her
angles
so there's no sight lines for people
surrounding her to see
you look stunned and poorly sir around
this sort of time period
in new york it would be 100 realistic
for pickpockets to be roaming the
streets
the best pickpockets i've seen are
female so sophie lyons the wife of
the king of bank robbers is that right
if i remember rightly but in 1538 there
was a lady called
moll cutpurse who was
a prolific pickpocket she was amazing
she used to dress up as a man smoke a
pipe
but she was renowned for allegedly
in the history books if you if you
google it doing
50 wallets a day or pocket wallets a day
i'll give it a 10 because you didn't see
anything and that's the whole point
i don't suppose you'd fancy a cup of tea
oh you're quite mistaken
it's animated so you can go that's not
realistic
but the technique of going in um is
realistic
this way a hand comes over into here
actually you'd probably
you'd notice that but if someone time
didn't come in front of him said oh can
you show me
where this place is they're covering
that over they're covering your
professional peripheral vision
so although you would do that you
wouldn't do that
not on its own and also the elastic on
the wallet
is also realistic because when i do my
show
i have a chain and i challenge
a volunteer to steal my wallet knowing
full well
it's attached to a chain it's animation
it's a fun
animation three you gonna tell me the
good news or
i know yeah but it's good news so i'm
telling you at the bar with a drink in
my hand okay well i'll meet you at the
barn and i'm just gonna
hit the bathroom really quick so the
keys are hanging
and his technique is unfortunately
exactly how you would take the keys
he grabs them to stop them from making a
noise
they're just the last bit of the key
pulling out of a pocket is really simple
to do
in fact he hasn't done anything but hold
the keys
she's moved away from the keys i've got
to say unfortunately yes
100 10 out of 10.
[Music]
in this old french movie they practice a
lot on
button jackets and he practices undoing
buttons
you might think that's a bit unrealistic
but it's actually very easy to do a lot
of people button
their jackets up and they think that
would be an obstacle
it's not helping you at all it is so
easy to go in
and to unbutton it's actually sometimes
harder to button you put your fingers
behind it you flick it
it comes out of the buttonhole really
easy
but maybe that was just slowed down for
the shot but uh in the motion
that would happen and i've done it
myself
and i've taken a purse with 3 000 pounds
in it credit cards gave it all back
obviously
for a pickpocketed awareness campaign
i'd give it
very aggressive compared to all the
other clips you've seen they're not
trying to be
like the gentleman thief like lupine or
ocean's 11
they are young are they naive
maybe they are i don't know but they're
going in hard and the chances are
they're going to get caught because
they're not trying to be secretive
i'm not impressed with their skill at
all
i would say they're really mugging them
rather than pickpocketing them
but what they are doing they're working
as that wolf pack gang mentality
creating the carnage of the distraction
especially walking over london bridge
for
sake of argument if you're on the phone
someone can snatch your phone pass it to
one of their
people behind them you turn around you
bump into me and go where's my phone
it's already gone down the line
from my two other people and it's the
confusion
that misdirection that you can't achieve
on your own as
easily forget it i'm not even gonna mark
it they're gonna get busted
they're not gonna last long there you
have got your wallet
but i got your credit cards